[Music]
well hey guys here here I am back once
again doing some of these reviews all on
my lonesome uh which I actually like
doing these to be honest and I thought
it was about time that I did another
book review as I said I'm still in the
middle of reading slooh foot by Braum uh
I just really haven't got around to like
reading that one yet I guess CU I have a
physical copy and I don't know for some
reason that's like harder for me to find
a place to sit down and read it so uh I
actually chose another ebook on my
Kindle unlimited so hopefully that's not
too much of a burden on anybody speaking
of books before I get too far into it uh
let me bring up our affiliate partner
for the video today which would be
audible now obviously audible is a
subset of Amazon and it is uh maybe the
world's largest uh repository of
audiobooks and uh podcasts any other
audio things you might want to listen to
now if you would like to subscribe to
Audible
there is a link in the description box
uh and if you click on that link which
is an affiliate link uh you know full
disclosure I get a small commission when
you do that and sign up but if you click
that link you will get a 30-day free
trial of audible and on top of that you
also get a free credit which you can
spend on whatever you want that you get
to keep forever while you have the
30-day trial um obviously you can listen
to whatever you want to listen to on
there with no points needed um also I
want to mention that if you already are
an Amazon Prime member then you will get
two uh credits with your uh
subscription and whatever you spend
those on you can keep those forever as I
said uh and the book we're talking about
today is on there obviously as are many
books that I wrote if you'd like to
listen to those as well so yeah uh click
on the link down in the description box
and sign up for Audible and uh it's a
really great service I use it myself and
I would recommend it very highly so
there you go all right so the book we're
talking out
today I kind of feel like okay so like
part of the fun of having a Kindle
unlimited subscription which is also
Amazon if you don't know um that's not
an affiliate but you basically pay um I
can't remember how much it is a month
but it's just like some it's like maybe
n bucks a month or 10 bucks or something
like that and there's millions and
millions of books available for on eBook
that you can just read for free like not
all of them are free obviously but you
know there's a huge huge selection and
so I signed up for that so I'd always
have a ready supply of books to read for
Booksie book reviews in case I couldn't
go and like buy a physical copy you know
what I mean so but I I found that like
part of the fun of having it having
Kindle unlimited is kind of playing a
game that I like to call Kindle roulette
uh and basically you know once they get
a feel for what your tastes are and like
you know once you've checked out like so
many books you know they can give you
better recommendations so I'll just go
and kind of browse through all of the
you know doz of recommendations they've
given me and I usually just choose a
book completely at random um sometimes
just from the title or from the cool
looking cover sometimes it's if it's
from an author that I've read before but
I usually try to pick different authors
every time so I'm not you know just
reading the same author over and over
again you know what I mean so I try to
pick somebody different um now I will
say that on occasion this method of just
picking stuff randomly has kind of
bitten me in the ass um and I'm thinking
in particular of that book I reviewed a
little while ago called hidden pictures
which was good all to you know all
together I guess like in the beginning
but then started getting a little
problematic toward the end um you know
go back and listen to my review if you
want to know what I'm talking about
there but I have to say that most of the
time um I end up with something that's
pretty entertaining you know what I mean
and uh that was absolutely the case with
the book we're talking about today now
this is a book called The Neighbor
written by uh London Clark who is from
South Carolina she's a South Carolina
author and this book actually came out
in
2021 I believe now this is actually the
first book of hers that I
read and I have to say I enjoyed it
quite a bit uh it's quite a page Turner
um I read it you know just almost I had
I had to read it in two sittings because
I didn't have time to like read the
whole thing through but it's like I
really didn't want to put it down I was
just like okay I'm just going to read
like one more chapter and then I have to
do some other [__] and then like that
didn't happen I was like okay maybe one
more chapter you know you know what I
mean so it was one of those kind of
things where I couldn't really put it
down you know
and the setup of it it's kind of cool I
kind of liked this actually the setup of
it is kind of like a domestic or
romantic Thriller like almost like
something you'd see on like the lifetime
channel or something like that you know
what I mean like one of those kind of
True Crime like my husband might be a
serial killer type of things like it's
kind of set up like that but then it
goes like in a more Supernatural dare I
say demonic Direction and I kind of dug
that like I kind of dug the the way that
it kind of juxtaposed those two things I
thought it worked out really
well so what is this book about so our
main
protagonist is named Claire vogle and
the entire story is told from her
perspective it's in the first person now
she is a therapist like a
psychotherapist and she is a the mother
of four
daughters however some recent incidents
that have taken place in her life um
have had her own mental health um maybe
not operating at Peak Performance let's
let's call it that now I believe it's
like a year prior to the events of the
novel her husband gunar divorced her and
it's made pretty clear that Claire still
loves him and kind of maybe lowkey hoped
that they were going to get back
together at some point however near the
beginning of the story um those hopes
are cruy dashed when gunar basically
like elopes or he remarries without
warning her without telling her like she
finds out from her kids who are like
spending their you know a lot of time
with them because they share custody you
know what I mean now this ends up
affecting Claire a lot more than she
thought it would like she tries to like
be cool about it and play it off but
it's obvious that she's like really
upset because like I said obviously now
you know they're not going to get back
together even though she kind of hoped
that they would now an interesting thing
about Claire is is that it seems in
times of stress she has over the years
developed something of an odd coping
mechanism although I don't know if I
want to call it that I think maybe like
escape hatch might be a better term what
she does is she kind of likes to dress
up kind of sexy like not like she would
normally dress you know what I mean she
goes to a bar or someplace where nobody
knows her and tries to like pick Pi up
random men now she always uses fake
names and fake completely fake details
about her life like about her job and
everything like that she just makes it
up at a whole cloth now she never
actually goes home with any of these
dudes or sleeps with them or anything
like that she just really enjoys
pretending to be someone else for a
little while and kind of seeing if she
can just like flirt with a dude and sort
of keep him on the hook with a
completely invented Persona without
having to like go all the way with it
you know what I mean it seems like a
little bit of a weird thing but that's
something that she does now she has
actually never told anybody about this
proclivity that she has and to be honest
she seems a little bit ashamed of it I
guess like she's a therapist so she
seems like she kind of knows why she
does it but she can't seem to stop
herself from doing it you know what I
mean so that's kind of another
intriguing thing because that's one of
the first things that she's introduced
doing like sitting at this bar like
pretending to be somebody else it's also
implied and the first part of the story
that Claire might have um suffered some
type of maybe trauma in her childhood
that she's completely repressed the
memory of of it but details about that
don't kind of come out until later on in
the story you just kind of get flashes
or like you know Visions or dreams or
something like that where she's
remembering something that clearly
happened to her but she doesn't really
remember what it is you know what I
mean so this is kind of the setup and
CLA is kind of you know she's getting by
she's working as a therapist and being a
mom to her four kids now there's a
little bit of foreshadowing at the
beginning of the story where this maybe
drunk Andor crazed woman starts banging
on the door of Claire's house in the
middle of the night screaming for
somebody named Patrick who obviously
does not live there because there are no
men living in the house CLA calls the
cops um they take the woman away and
even though Claire thinks the whole
thing is kind of weird which obviously
it is she figures oh you know maybe the
woman was just confused or wasted and
she just went to the wrong house it's
like no big deal right so she doesn't
really think that much more about it and
the interesting thing is that the reader
also kind of forgets about it a little
bit until later on when it kind of comes
back you know what I mean because it's a
long time before like you find out what
the deal with that was now the
neighborhood that Claire lives in is
pretty
close-knit and she particip Ates in a
book club which is really kind of more
like a wine mom party that they have
every week or whatever um with a bunch
of other women who live on the same
street now at one of these get togethers
the women are just all AB Buzz with news
of the new guy in the neighborhood uh
this very handsome and you know
seemingly single dude who's renting the
house next door to Claire's now she
hasn't really seen much of him like the
little she's seen of him like he's had
like a hoodie on or sung glasses she
couldn't really tell what he looked like
or anything like that and she's like
look I just got divorced I'm not ready
for this [__] anymore so it's like she's
really not interested even though she's
you can tell she kind of is still but
she pretends like she's not um but you
know all the other ladies are you know
just intrigued and like all a flutter
about this now it turns out that the
guy's name is steel Nolan which made I
mean seeing that name the first time it
I just busted out laughing because I
think that the I'm kind of getting the
impression that the author is kind of
definitely trying to make some Sly joke
about the romance novel genre because
that is like the most harleyquinn
romance name that I think I've ever
heard steel [__] Nolan you know what
I mean it's just well his middle name is
not [__] but you know what I mean
steel Nolan I was just kind of like oh
my God that is such a that is such a
Fabio name I'm just I was like I'm sure
there's like a whole romance novel the
series the steel no but I think she did
that on purpose you know what I mean
because you know you kind of find out
why if you read the book now not
surprisingly steel Nolan is this big
hunky Dreamboat who apparently like runs
his own construction business he's got
like all these teams and he's kind of
working on some uh places in the area
like some uh housing developments in the
area and one evening he kind of like
pokes his head through Claire's Back
Fence while she's out on her deck like
he's out there smoking or whatever now
the fence and her backyard shed were
blown down in a storm like a few months
before or whatever and she just has
hasn't had the time to get around to
like fixing it now steel says oh that's
no problem at all um I'll fix it all up
for you I'll even Rebel rebuild the shed
like completely all for free now Claire
understandably um is pretty reluctant to
take him up on this generous offer cuz
like you'd be like suspicious right it's
like what does this dude want in return
you know what I mean but I mean she does
have to admit that he's very charming
and he seems like a great guy like he
doesn't seem like obnoxious or pushy or
like he's trying to get something out of
her or nothing like that he seems like
pretty chill and he's basically like
pretty insistent look I want to do this
work for you I won't let you pay me I
you know I I don't expect anything in
return I just like to help people you
know please let me do it and so after a
while she finally like gives in you know
what I mean and lets him he's like okay
fine you can do it if you want
to now I know and you know that this guy
is way too good to be true and in this
case just as in most of the time in real
life um you would be absolutely correct
to think that he is too good to be true
and as much as Claire tries to fight her
feelings for him she ends up kind of
drawn into this real Torrid like sexual
relationship way against her better
judgment and she kind of finds like her
thoughts are just becoming consumed by
him she can't seem to like control
herself when he's around all this kind
of stuff like whenever they get together
she's like okay this can't happen again
this can't happen again then she ends up
jumping on the Dick anyway almost like
she's like losing control of herself you
know what I mean now steel for his part
um also claims to be falling for her as
well and even kind of implies that maybe
things are starting to get really
serious between them he's like you know
I you know not to the point where it's
like oh marriage or anything but he's
like you know I'd like to be part of
your kids' lives and I'd like to you
know I'd like us to move in together and
all this other kind of stuff so stuff's
like getting kind of serious right and
she's freaking out a little bit but she
also can't stop stop thinking about him
in another
way however very soon because this is a
horror novel um kind of crack start to
appear in this you know Blissful
lovey-dovey
situation for one thing and this was one
of the most intriguing things I loved
this setup Claire has started seeing
because like I said she's a therapist
she started seeing a new patient named
Whitney and Whitney like every time she
comes to the office like her life events
quite bizarrely start to mirror Claire's
life events like she comes there and
goes oh this happened and that she's
like that's [__] weird that's the
same thing that happened to me this past
week you know what I mean it's like it's
it's super creepy like I don't know why
that like creeped me out so much but it
really did I was like oo what's going on
there you know what I mean um and during
one of Whitney's sessions it comes to
light that Whitney might also be dating
steel even though steel never mentioned
that he was seeing anyone else and
seemed to imply that he was getting
serious about CLA and that they were
heading toward exclusivity or whatever
now CLA later confronts him about it and
he just vehemently denies I am not
seeing another woman I don't know what
she's talking about I don't even know
her blahy blah but Whitney seems to know
a lot about him you know what I mean so
Claire isn't really sure what to think
other than she knows that one of these
[__] is lying and she doesn't
know which one of it is now she
eventually gets so desperate that she
hires like a private investigator to
look into Steel's background and he
comes up with some uh pretty disturbing
information which I'm not going to
spoil also on top of all of this going
on because like I said that's kind of
the setup that's sort of like a domestic
thriller or like like I said something
that you would see like on the Lifetime
network or you know like a true crime
kind of show or something like that but
there's also a supernatural aspect
because there are also some creepy and
very clearly paranor normal things
happening in Claire's house such as um
like random Shadows that look like
people sort of like moving across the
walls somebody calling her name when
nobody is there like she hears voices
and stuff there is like this stuffed cat
that belongs to her daughter Paris uh
which seems to kind of like move around
on its own and is kind of creepy as [__]
and her eldest daughter whose name is
analine um starts acting real weird like
she starts sleepwalking like going out
in the street in the middle of the night
and doing really weird things that she
claims not to remember later and she
starts getting real um antagonistic and
stuff like that where she wasn't before
Claire also starts seeing this really
terrifying man in a leather hat who is
clearly not a real person because he
kind of like appears and disappears at
will like he pops up in the backseat of
her car and [__] like that and she
starts also having something like real
disturbing Visions after visiting this
weird mysterious website whose address
she finds on this business card that
somebody we don't know who like left in
her car so crazy stuff also starts
happening like in The Wider neighborhood
as well like there's like for example at
one house there's a horrific like murder
suicide at one of the houses another
neighbor too who's this Korean woman
named hayo she believes that some kind
of poor
has opened in the neighborhood um and
she keeps referring to all these holes
in the ground um but for a while nobody
really pays her all that much
attention so as The Story Goes On And as
events get more and more
unhinged um Claire is getting kind of
more and more desperate and she ends up
having to essentially
reassess her nonbelief because she lost
her belief in God her dad was an
exorcist which kind of plays into the
story a little bit later um but she lost
her faith so she kind of has to reassess
whether she actually believes in God and
demons and things like that and as she
gets weirder and weirder she starts
Consulting like psychics and paranormal
investigators and exorcists eventually
to kind of get to the bottom of what's
happening to her family specifically and
the residents of the street at large
because it seems to be infecting like a
wider area um she's also kind of dealing
with a lot of guilt I guess because she
suspects that her relationship with
steel was the Catalyst for all of these
kind of disasters that like followed in
you know in the wake of it now I
actually I read a couple of other
Reviews of This Book like on Goodreads
and Amazon and stuff and I noticed that
more than one person compared it
favorably to the movie Poltergeist from
1982 um and I would consider that like
as far as it goes like I guess a fairly
accurate comparison in that it's kind of
set in an upper middle class suburb and
involves kind of dark Forces trying to
capture the souls of people in the house
and in the neighborhood and stuff like
that so in that sense it's kind of
similar to Poltergeist so I kind of get
where that's coming from I also saw a
couple people um say that it had a Vibe
somewhat similar to the Grady Hendrick
novel um the southern book clubs guide
to slaying vampires which I reviewed a
while back um and I think that's also a
pretty astute assessment I mean cuz in
the sense that that's also about a bunch
of ladies in a book club who have to
fight like a paranormal like a
supernatural being or something like
that so it's kind of similar in that
regard I guess um but I'm but the
neighbor has its own thing going on so
it's not really the same as either of
those but it's kind of somewhere in that
same ballpark so if you like that kind
of stuff then you will probably like
this as well so I mean for me personally
like I said I liked this a lot um you
know it's it's real fast-paced and it
really kind of kept my attention like
the whole time and I just couldn't stop
reading it you know and I really
particularly liked how it took some of
the tropes of like a romance novel or a
domestic Thriller you know kind of like
oh you know recently divorced woman
falling for the hot bad boy next door
which is pretty common as far as that
goes like in that genre and kind of do
starting with that but then like going
in a supernatural Direction that I
thought that was a good idea rather than
just you know having the guy turn out to
be a serial killer or something like
that for example which like I said I
think every lifetime crime movie is like
that where it's like I fell in love with
this dude and I found out he was a zero
killer you know what I mean but it this
kind of is set up like that but then it
goes in a supernatural Direction which I
thought was kind of cool um now I will
note that there is something of a serial
killer aspect in the story but it's very
minor it's kind of more of like a
background plot element than like the
main thing you know what I'm saying so
that is kind of in there but but it's it
factors into the plot a little bit but
not but not a huge amount it's mostly
Supernatural now if I had any criticism
which I have very little criticism of
this because I really liked it a lot um
but probably my only criticism would be
that I feel like a few of the characters
were probably like unnecessary um and
could have been trimmed out like for
example um you know she had four
daughters and I think really two of them
didn't really do much of anything or
didn't really contribute much to the
plot so it's like I don't know why she
necessarily had to have four daughters
instead of maybe just two uh you know
what I mean because like I said two of
them were major characters but the other
two were just I don't even remember what
their names were you know what I mean um
also there was like a couple characters
like for example this the first psychic
that she calls to come to the house like
to deal with whatever this paranormal
[__] is that's going on in her house and
this first psychic that comes like comes
there and says oh well there's nothing
here and I feel like that scene Pro I
mean that didn't really contribute much
to the plot so I didn't really
necessarily think that had to be there
um and I'm going to say too that like
the Exorcist that gets introduced toward
the end did also didn't really wind up
doing much of anything and I think that
he should have been introduced earlier
and been more of like a character or he
could have been eliminated altogether
but I think it would have been a better
idea for him to be you know introduced
much earlier because the you have the
Exorcist but then there's a bunch of
paranormal investigators like working in
there too so you could have like just
combined all of that into like a couple
of characters instead of just adding new
characters you know what I mean but like
I said that's a very very minor
criticism it's in a me all that much um
because overall I mean I thought this
was a really um a really compelling
story it moved forward it had a lot of
really good momentum um it didn't really
slow down for a minute it was very like
I said it was really fast-paced no slow
spots I not that I noticed um and I
really loved the buildup of all the
weird details like who like who's this
spooky man in the leather hat that keeps
popping up and you know the character of
Whitney her um patient who has exactly
the same things happened to her that
were happening to Claire and I'm just
like that's really weird what's going on
there um and I also really liked the
kind of slow roll out of information
about steel Nolan that was like coming
to light through Claire interacting with
the private investigator that she hired
you know what I mean um and each detail
just got weirder and weirder like you
know each one was weirder than the last
one so it really kind of like kept you
like glued to the page so you could
figure out what the [__] like what
exactly this guy's deal is and how does
this relate to all this other stuff
that's going on so yeah so definitely if
you really like um you know you just
want to read something that's creepy and
kind of fast-paced um a supernatural
horror with you know really good
characters and kind of an interesting
story angle that's growing out of a
standard domestic Thriller but then
going in kind of like a demonic sort of
Direction um I would definitely
recommend this I thought it was really
really good seems to have gotten like
mostly really really positive reviews
and I can see why um it's just like a
really ener raining horror novel and it
actually had some real scary [__] going
on in it and um you know I just really
likeed the buildup and the Myster and
everything like that so I thought it was
pretty great and uh if you have Kindle
unlimited you can read the ebook for
free uh or like I said if you click down
in the uh description box for a free
30-day trial of audible then you can
listen to the audiobook so that would be
cool too so yeah um so I guess I'll wrap
it up for this book review Thanks you
guys so much for listening uh remember
to like share comment subscribe all that
kind of stuff if you haven't done all of
that already and I'll see you guys again
on uh tomorrow night's show good
night